[Applauso]
[Musica]
io resto a chi e come sto a chi non ci
sta a nessuno a proposito non so se vi
ricordate parte cristiano ronaldo fifa
2019 ok ecco io ho in anteprima oggi
fifa 2019 e voglio giocarlo con voi
quindi lescot 3g wan via come ci si
muove non so ma io sono quella sinistra
a destra aiuto io mi muovo così
personaggi ben chiaro comunque questo
fifa 19 in anteprima mi piace un sacco
soprattutto quei due per come sono
spaccati bel cristiano è cristiano
cristiano che siano la butta in mezzo no
non la butta e me fa e neymar però non è
che poi fa sempre così a ragazzi il
problema non è fifa in se il problema è
i ragazzi secondo me qua ci sono troppe
simulazioni troppe cioè senso la gente
cade mai lata non si è fatta nessuno si
sta toccando il portiere ha delle
convulsioni dovute all'alcol della sera
prima ragazzi in porta veloci pogba
bravissimo ma che difesa
ora che c'è bonucci lì che sposta gli
equilibri bravissimo guardano guardalo
ora come sposta l'equilibrio
guardalo non ce l'ha proprio equilibrio
hai finito il tempo va bene che cosa
state facendo di sudano le ascelle a
tutti quanti time out
69 un'ora team sites 32 per madonna ball
frate palle a ci sono anche più palle va
bene c'è un po di palle in meno c'è un 3
palle in campo un pelo più piccolo ball
size ragazzi che lo stiamo vedendo
va bene 321 vai penso che questo sia
molto più equilibrata ripartita ai
ragazzi però ci puoi vedere la palla in
porta questi non sa neanche toccare la
palla ma pesa più di loro il pallone ma
vai vai vai tira tira guarda lo guardano
naldo guardano mi si distingue guardali
compressa va ai ragazzi dai ragazzi
tutti importa tutti in porta forza
michiara jan25 per fare entro un pallone
non è impossibile devo diminuire un po
di roba
io direi di fare molto molto umile uno
contro uno porte giganti via
no dai tir a latera sei scemo e scemo
dai amico mio non puoi non segnare
madama come ho fatto a non segnare poi
fai incastrati nel legno della porta ma
togliti nono a 0 devi prendere dei brand
del porco lo schifo in terra come ho
fatto a perdere 10 cosa esulti fa
veramente schifo continue match stavolta
ti vogl i o carico zio carico ma avete
comprato gli arbitri secondo me terzo
tentativo
niente svenuto prima life rate mai fra
sulla palla sulla palla sulla palla
cristiano cristiano cristiano cristia ci
avete una resistenza da da premio nobel
comunque se qualcuno riesce a toccare la
palla
ok no dall'altra parte nell'altro porta
madonna e sulla riga previa corri veloce
prima karimi lui è normale che somiglia
un po a gigi d'alessio tizio che ha
preso il palo ha preso il palo preso il
palo vai vai vai c'è competizione 0
comunque die like è scemo e scemo e
scemo scemo ha preso delle sedi ieri non
andare contro la palla che entra in
porta fa giro piano penso su su su no va
bene avere la sagra tocchi dall'altra
parte di latina dio di l'acqua come
contento non ha fatto niente ma regala
un gol cia posso fare a farlo veloce
veloce sulla palla cosa fa breakdance
prendilo prendilo il pallone prendilo
premi lo supera ma eleganti ed ep saluto
caro
di solito carota ammazzo ti ammazzo la
famiglia ti ammazzo devi toccare il
pallone devi solo toccare il pallone
devi niente neanche quelli dai ma non
entra non entra mai tar caro ancora
tocchi niente svenuto e quello che si
sta rimandando il varo forza dei sotto
candy risolto carlo ha toccato che hai
dentro da gesù un'ora per fa 4 a 1 in
conca ragazzi sto gioco veramente
l'apoteosi del nulla va bene facciamo
con un team size un po più capiente un
po più di distanza magari alle porte è
un po più piccole le porte se vuoi per
mettere hanno mica posso fare anche la
forte mignon prova così per curiosità
porca non entra mai ma neanche senza
l'avversario non riesco a farlo entrare
impossibile ma siamo qua fino a domani
si tira tira sei lì se li se li ti prego
ti prego non far pagare se li devi solo
andare dritto dritto dritto di quadri
tricot dritto dritto dritto dritto ma
dritto non fa niente cambiamo partiamo
ecco perché la partenza è sbagliata
tutti sulla palla tutti tutti non solo
quelle centro tutti bello sto fifa
occhio occhio gol 11 mormon esulta
esulta esulta bravi limonate vi
bravissimi era gara finale dei mondiali
dal trono è andata così
queste francia croazia attenzione
controllo manzo chi c'e ancora lui
ecco lo intercetta il pallone non lo
intercetta pensava di pace tra
l'attenzione parte ancora il griezmann
griezmann bravo griezmann è morto
quanti chili in più hanno sti giocatori
quanto hanno bevuto ma cosa fate voi due
là dietro e andare verso la palla invece
gli stalli vabbè break dance sulla porta
va bene uguale sostiamo l'onestà rock o
mio dio non volevo fare questo è non me
la ricordavo stata funzione quando avevo
giocato la prima volta però va bene
posso picchiare la gente da lontano
aspetta un perfetto comunque ragazzi nel
caso non lo sapeste libro dico io questo
gioco è stato sviluppato dagli stessi
creatori di su motori dreams
l'avreste mai detto è esattamente quello
di cui ho bisogno
hanno visto il suo motore nissan detto
ci piace la fisica di questo gioco
facciamo di fare ti fa 19 ovviamente e
questo è il risultato
quello non cade ma neanche coi cannoni
che è possibile far cadere quel tizio
littoral dell'anno da nora non cade
manco morto
ora che aiuto ecco eccoli perfetto ci ho
messo un ora comunque è veramente carino
se non fosse che sono tutti un po morti
però dettagli signore di ieri provare
una partita decente tutti sulla palla
qualcuno farà gol prima o poi vedo tutti
sulla pa a tutti tutti voglio carichi
porca vacca carichi non come l'italia
mondiali che siamo usciti
ecco giocavamo più o meno così ai
mondiali disastro st succede occchio è
un'attenzione o incredibile cavolo ci ho
creduto fortissimo 20 ma porca vacca
mort possiamo farlo entrare da dietro la
palla però è che non ci vanno i
giocatori dietro ai spingi spingi spingi
spingi la ok dovreste riuscire a
portarla davanti nel dubbio prova a
tracciare dal in calcia da dentro la
porta dall'altra parte della porta va
bene uguale penso cercare il gol in
questo gioco come evadere dalla franzoni
è impossibile vabbè che già è difficile
per cortesia almeno non portiamo la
palla in luoghi sconsiderati almeno
calcia dalla parte giusta
rifacciamo credo 1 let's go bike sto
impegnando tantissimo esso gioco c'è un
gioco tattico e qualcuno riuscisse a
sport amate e alla gente sfonda la porta
dell'avversario poi al problema
vai vai vai vai che ci sei dai che ci
sei dai che ci sei dai che ci sei
male inizia prima o poi riuscirò a fare
entrare stava alla la vedo neanche più
l'ho perso limitato la perdo pure figure
che sono tutti miei tra l'altro i
giocatori come fa la palla stare lì
ferma sono tutti i miei solo lui e
quello che vi vende tutti gli altri sono
miei
buttate là dentro per cortesia bravo
bravo il top mezzo un tocco in mezzo il
tuo che mezzo il cross cross ottimo
cross dio mio ma come può essere così
difficile e no no no no no no vabbè
vabbè dai è un os fitto fino a
sfondargli la famiglia come hanno fatto
a riva ma da
ma dai ma dai ma va a cagare va ma
dovete morire
l'ho spinto fino a guarda guarda la mia
porta commentato guarda loro come hanno
fatto con loro come dai minchia in
psicologia svenuto in partenza 1 a 0
direi che possiamo farcela questo gol da
me lo sento
no palo grazie a gesù caccia via caccia
via caccia via cacciari a non sfondare
la porta calcia via la palla
ok ma neanche contro i campioni del
mondo di rocket league avevo dato così
tanto lega ma comunque fare un gol così
impossibile ragazzi devo fare meno
persone ok così è fattibile
c'è poi quale siamo al limite perché
sennò la palla si incastra o segnano
solo loro si incastrava alla gigi gigi
va da ibrahimovic e vai vai scatta lo
voglio vedere scattante bravissimo loro
la caccia non la palla come fanno
ok ottima scoperto si può calciare il
pallone non era scontato però se
riusciamo a fare una porta avversaria
sono più contento vabbè tira tira tira
tira che forse era meglio non scoprirlo
chigi ma prendi la la prendi la con
demonio morto ragazzi veramente
difficile gesù non è arbitro
vendutissimo pure 11 no palo prendi la
caccia carte ma non a lui a cristo di
gesù che te qualche gol bellissimo un
crollo fatto gol della madonna 1 con
l'ha sfondata la porta col naso ci
sollecita a segnare di testa
un gioco così beh mica i passaggi
addirittura sono arrivati i passaggi per
riuscire alla mancata corre verso la
palla ma i passaggi bravo ottimo calcio
all'inizio passaggio non aldo bravo
ronaldo morto troppi schemi calcistici
da ricordare tira ti prego no gigi gol
grazie gesù
grazie non è neanche gol l'abbiamo pure
rubata però vabbè vabbè ragazzi a sto
punto di provare tutto al massimo giusto
prevedere che succede ragazzi in questo
momento storico nel calcio va ricordato
perché secondo me qua ce la facciamo è
un po difficile per carità di dio però
secondo me ce la possiamo fare
ok ok ok questa volta buona questa volta
me lo sento me lo sento me lo sento che
la volta buona veit neymar
neymar neymar ancora lui neymar bravo
neymar bravo rimase lì salta tutti
neymar
se li salta tutti neymar bravissimo
neymar cade per terra neymar simulazione
di neymar ma non importa vai avanti
ragazzi dopo forse un'ora di tentativi
di controllo palla stiamo giungendo a
dei minimi risultati di avvicinamento
alla porta
mi sento fantozzi
[Musica]